it seems that throughout history and
still in the world today
religion has been a source of some of
the of a lot of polarization a lot of
conflict even War
um why do you think that is
listen I think at the essence of it
is always some sort of political
instability
that leaves behind a brutalized
population
and vulnerabilities that can be
exploited
as I said in the 20th century
with the bloodiest Century that we've
had to date
where does religion fall in any of that
where does religion fall in the isms
where does religion fall in the world
wars
where does religion fall and and much of
that even when we talk about things like
the Crusades remove the Islamic framing
the Crusades the Crusades were they
really about religion the Mongols and
the destruction of the Mongols was it
about religion
Myanmar and the rohingya today is it
about Buddhism so I think that these are
essentially political issues political
causes where you have people that rise
up and that use religion to disguise
things that are far far far from
religion and if you want to manipulate a
religious scripture you could turn any
book
any Scripture until a violent scripture
if you have a violent Aim so I think
that that's where you find people
manipulating versus manipulating
religion
uh to justify sick ideologies
that are based
and thrive in political instability so
these are fundamentally political
geopolitical conflicts not religious
conflicts absolutely look when you talk
about a group like Isis
Islam has been in Iraq for a very very
long time
Iraq has been bombed by now five
consecutive presidents or four it's been
bombed into the stone ages
there is no political infrastructure
it's Devastation and destruction and
Desperation as a result of that
many of the old Saddam Loyalists and
saddam's regime was was a secularist
regime uh are now heads of Isis right it
just moved into that when you create
that type of Chaos
you generate an environment where groups
like Isis are bound to rise out of
and so
Islam did not you know cause this people
didn't wake up in Iraq one day and say
hey let's create a group called Isis
because Islam tells us to
right
Iraq was bombed in two this place
and we have to not just free religion
from the responsibility from having to
Bear the responsibility
of much of the hatred and violence but
we have to interrogate
the political instability that was
caused
were we Justified
As Americans these are a taxpayer
dollars were we Justified
with what was done in Iraq do we even
know what was done in Iraq and
Afghanistan
these drones that drop using our tax
dollars under Democratic and Republican
regimes
and kill
thousands of innocent people in weddings
in Yemen and Somalia
are these Justified when you think about
dehumanization
can the average American name a single
victim of the Iraq War
is there a picture that comes to your
mind is there a person absolutely not
because that's the dehumanization
now I often talk about Dr Martin Luther
King Jr his progression as a faith
leader in America as a political leader
in America Dr King was deeply unpopular
when he took a stand on Vietnam and he
mentions how first he had to see
Vietnam
through the lens of the soldiers because
many of the soldiers that were lost
American soldiers right and that was
that was a crime that they were sent to
fight a war that they should not have
been sent to fight and
there was an injustice that was done
towards them he said but things really
changed when he started to see it from
the other side of the bullet when he
started to see the world through Vietnam
through the Vietnamese child
and that's where he resorted to Breaking
the silence that's where he changed his
tune because we dehumanize our victims
so much that they're not even relevant
to our discourse until they become able
villains
to our story
and then now they're attacking us
because they hate us now they're blowing
us up because they hate us their
religion tells them to do this to us
what have we allowed to be done to them
using our tax dollars
in our name
right so I think that we have to
interrogate the political chaos that was
caused not just not just free religion
from the groups that were created but
what was done to those countries and
what continues to be done in many of
these places yeah when um
the The Pride that people had about
America where everybody came together
after 9 11 and there was all the
American flags
that was beautiful to see but then you
have to transfer that and I wish all of
us Americans could go and see the
daughters that would lose their parents
the parents that would lose their
daughters and sons because the bombs
dropped
um the the thousands the tens of
thousands of civilians that died
um in Afghanistan and in Iraq because of
the decisions made
in the name of politics like if we just
met those families and if you if we if
we empathize with them and just put
ourselves in their place
uh it's impossible not to feel hate
for America for everybody I mean I I
visited Ukraine and spoke to a lot of
ukrainians and they said um
you know there's there's loved ones that
are Russians before the war but now all
they have is hate
and uh if you ask many of them will they
ever forgive not not not the regime
not the soldiers will they ever forgive
Russians they many of them say never
and that never feels like it's a
generational never
um I mean look
you think about this you know if your
grandparents were wiped out in a drone
attack your parents
your brothers your sisters all of your
loved ones and you're missing a leg and
an eye
and the world does not take you into
consideration you'll never be seen or
considered in the halls of Congress or
discussed
what are you going to grow up with right
but the thing is is that we should not
be speaking about this only from the
standpoint of oh shoot they're going to
grow up and hate us
we should be thinking about what was
done to them and hate that
despise that that it's ugly you see when
people carry out a terrorist attack
they're not considering
the lives of the civilians and these
places so those that perpetrate the 9 11
attacks are not seeing
the thousands of people that they killed
the human beings the Lives Many of whom
are Muslim by the way actually no one of
them was a very active Muslim in Islamic
circle of North America
I mean
they didn't see those stories right
when you drop a bomb
on this many people when you drone
people and you say oops collateral
damage
we were looking for one person killed 40
people and there's no count no names
nothing that can be recalled in the
American memory
that's a problem a fundamental issue
with how we treat the rest of the world
right so
I'm an American I I I think that I'm
responsible to the extent that I have to
critique these policies and I have to
try to you know challenge America to
deal with the world differently
and when I go overseas
when I'm around Muslims in the Muslim
world right in the Middle East and in
the Muslim world
you know I have to I'm speaking as a
Palestinian American Muslim who grew up
in south Louisiana I've got a complex
background here right a lot of
experiences here that I'm grateful for
because they all contribute to
uh
who I who I am and who what I know and
what I've been I think they're all
enriching I wouldn't relinquish the
Palestinian part I wouldn't relinquish
the American part and I certainly
wouldn't relinquish the Muslim part
but it's helping people consider
what they're not seeing and when you can
dehumanize entire groups of people
to where you can reduce them to chalk
casualty counts and not be able to
recall a single story
then you have to take a step back and
ask yourself what are we becoming
right what are we becoming not a single
victim of Afghanistan or Iraq millions
of people not a single person
can the average American conjure in
their head